das wäre wirklich sensationell haben
forscher jetzt eine hypothese für die
dunkle energie entwickelt die sie uns
schon bald im universum beobachten lässt
bisher ist die dunkle energie eine bloße
spekulation ohne sie können wir aber die
expansion des weltalls nicht erklären
können wir mit der neuen hypothese schon
bald die dunkle energie aufschwimmen bzw
mehrere dunkle energie bee bitte wieso
weshalb warum jetzt in klicks substanz
im future gibt es dreimal pro woche
spannende science videos abonniert den
kanal und aktiviert die glocke nur so
verpasst ihr nichts los geht's herzlich
willkommen
das weltall dehnt sich mit rasender
geschwindigkeit aus und das macht es
auch noch mehr als mysteriös denn
eigentlich dürfte sich das weltall nicht
immer schneller ausbreiten wie bei einer
explosion müsste die ausdehnung nach
außen hin immer langsamer werden weil
sich die gleiche menge energie im raum
verteilen muss und so immer weniger
energie zur verfügung steht also pro
rauminhalt und dieser effekt müsste
dramatisch sein einer explosion kommt ja
innerhalb von extrem kurzer zeit zum
erliegen nicht aber das universum im
gegenteil
und das eben auch noch auf eine sehr
mysteriöse art und weise denn je nachdem
wie diese expansion gemessen wird sind
die ergebnisse vollkommen verschieden
der wert dafür ist die hubble konstante
sie besagt um wie viel kilometer die
ausdehnung geschwindigkeit pro
megaparsec steigt ein paar zach ist eine
astronomische einheit und das ist der
abstand zwischen erde und sonne und ein
megaparsec das sind eine million
astronomische einheiten was 3 millionen
260.000 lichtjahren entspricht und je
nachdem wie man diese hubble konstante
misst kommen ganz unterschiedliche
ergebnisse heraus wir haben ja über
diese krise der hubble konstante
berichtet wissenschaftlich gesehen da
ist das eigentlich eine katastrophe denn
umso genauer man den wert der hubble
konstante bestimmen will desto ungenauer
werden die ergebnisse oder
unterschiedlicher das ist wirklich
paradox denn die messergebnisse werden
eigentlich immer genauer aber liegen
immer deutlicher auseinander
die forschenden versuchen bei jedem
verfahren ein möglichst exaktes ergebnis
zu erzielen
aber je nach verfahren sind die
ergebnisse vollkommen anders zur messung
der
pensionen des universums werten
himmelskörper herangenommen von denen
man ganz exakt weiß wie hell und wie
heißt sie sind wie bei einem leuchtturm
weiß die forschung so viel über diese
himmelskörper dass sehr viele weitere
werte an ihnen bestimmt werden können
unter anderem eben die hubble konstante
denn sie beschreibt die geschwindigkeit
mit der das universum auseinanderfliegt
und das tut das universum mit
zunehmender entfernung mit immer höherer
geschwindigkeit die habe konstante
beschreibt deshalb auch keine feste
geschwindigkeit sondern die zunahme der
geschwindigkeit mit steigender
entfernung erst anfang der zehnerjahre
wurden die daten des blank
weltraumteleskops veröffentlicht es
lieferte die bislang detailreichsten
karte der kosmischen
hintergrundstrahlung und eine konstante
von 67,7 vier kilometern pro sekunde je
megaparsec das spitzer weltraumteleskop
lieferte dagegen anhand von cp eben
einen anderen wert diese sterne
verändern periodisch ihre leuchtkraft
und größe um bis hilfe der dauer der
periode kann ihre leuchtkraft definiert
werden
das ergebnis des spitzer
weltraumteleskops lag bei 74,3 das
hubble-weltraumteleskop mit zufrieden
und supernovae vom typ 1a lieferte 74,2
die beiden werte liegen ja wenigstens
einigermaßen beieinander
und wenn man berücksichtigt dass beide
messungen eine abweichung von plus minus
2,1 kilometer pro sekunde und megaparsec
mal spitzer und 3,6 beim
hubble-weltraumteleskop zu lassen dann
decken sich die ergebnisse fast zunichte
machen das aber weder die messungen an
gravitationslinsen also so starken
gravitations feldern zum beispiel um
galaxien die das licht von objekten wie
eine linse so stark krümmen dass
galaxien dahinter zwei oder sogar vier
mal auftauchen dabei legt das licht
unterschiedliche wege zurück zum einen
sind es tatsächlich umwege durch die
krümmung der raumzeit in der
gravitationslinse und zum anderen
unterliegt ein lichtstrahl der durch den
dichteren teil der gravitationslinse zu
uns gelangt größeren relativistischen
effekten das heißt einer größeren zeit
die nation die zeit im lichtstrahl läuft
langsamer
das sind effekte von einigen wochen und
monaten das ergebnis 69 7 kilometer pro
sekunde und megaparsec die wissenschaft
steht vor einem rätsel
oder vielleicht doch
nicht denn jetzt hat ein forschungsteam
von der pariser sorbonne universität
einen bahnbrechenden vorschlag
vielleicht gibt es nicht nur eine dunkle
energie
wie bitte ok es wird nicht einfacher das
higgs feld wechselt wirkt mit materie
und gibt ihr masse das dafür
verantwortliche explosion wurde erst im
juli 2012 im large hadron collider kurz
lhc in genf gefunden
bei der dunklen energie vermutet man ein
ähnliches phänomen bei der angewandten
fällt mit den teilchen interagiert die
bei der quanten fluktuation im vakuum
entstehen bei der quantenfluktuationen
entstehen im vakuum teilchen und
antiteilchen sie sich dann wieder sofort
gegenseitig zerstrahlen außer am
ereignishorizont von schwarzen löchern
aber das ist ein anderes thema im
letzten jahr wurde diese
quantenfluktuationen übrigens das erste
mal gemessen
der 40 kilogramm schwere spiegel des
laico gravitationswellen detektors wird
durch die virtuellen teilchen um den 100
milliarden durchmesser des
wasserstoffatoms bewegt jetzt haben die
forscherinnen um jascha gramm von der
verband eine bahnbrechende idee dieses
paradoxon der unkonstanten hubble
konstante lösen könnte nicht einfällt
wie beim ixs welt und der masse ist für
die dunkle energie verantwortlich es
sind mehrere felder und diese ansatzlos
tatsächlich mehrere probleme dunkle
energie mit multiplen feldern ist
unserer ansicht nach theoretisch gut
begründbar und sie sagt bestimmte
beobachtbare merkmale voraus so das
forschungsteam in seiner arbeit ihre
these mehrere quanten felder
wechselwirken mit den teilchen der
konten fluktuation und mit den teig in
der normalen materie und auch
miteinander denn bei nur einem konnten
fällt müssten die werte da habe
konstante überall gleich sein sind sie
aber offensichtlich nicht dazu das
forschungsteam die modelle die wir hier
betrachten beschreiben eine form der
dunklen in der
die cluster bilden kann sprich hier kann
es unterschiede bei der dunklen energie
geben und das sind dann genau die
unterschiede die auch beobachtet wurden
dazu muss man sagen dass sich die
untersuchungsobjekte auch in sehr
unterschiedlichen bereichen befinden
während supernovae und zufrieden nur in
unserer milchstraße beobachtet werden
können sind gravitationslinsen deutlich
weiter entfernt solche riesigen materie
kunden gibt es nur als dunkle materie
schwarze löcher oder riesige galaxien
oder galaxienhaufen also außerhalb
unserer galaxie sehr weit entfernt also
nicht ein paar tausend lichtjahre
sondern eher millionen oder milliarden
lichtjahre sprich die
untersuchungsobjekte befinden sich ein
komplett anderen orten im universum und
genau das könnte die unterschiedlichen
ergebnisse verursachen so die forscher
sie gehen davon aus dass die dunkle
energie sogar klumpen bilden kann und
damit sehr deutliche abweichung von der
hubble konstante möglich werden sie
könnten so stark sein dass sie wie
gravitationslinsen auch mit teleskopen
beobachtet werden können spricht es
kommt eine weitere aufgabe auf das james
webb weltraumteleskop zu das diesen
herbst richtung rundum laufbahn auf der
sonnen abweisenden seite der erde
gestattet sind dort liegt es im
erdschatten und kann mit seiner
gigantischen größe der riesigen
auflösung und der 100 fach höheren
empfindlichkeit als das hubble
weltraumteleskop phänomene sichtbar
machen die uns bisher vollkommen
verborgen geblieben sind man kann sagen
die welt bekommt im herbst 2021 eine
neue brille
ich bin schon wahnsinnig gespannt auf
die ersten bilder das wird absolut meint
bloggen und jetzt eines der größten
rätsel der kosmologie die
quantenfluktuationen führt zu einem
absolut absurden phänomen schwarze
löcher verdampfen mit der zeit sie lösen
sich auf durch die hawking strahlung
nachweis der hawking strahlung an
wirklich absolut verblüffendes phänomen
also anklicken anschauen und abonnieren
jeder und jede ist hier willkommen wir
geben uns wirklich wahnsinnig viel mühe
um hier die spannendsten phänomene
einfach und trotzdem umfassend zu
erklären also don't miss abo knopf bis
dann
bleibt dran